字幕: Takuma Suzuki
校正: Hiroko Kawano
ラジコン空撮ばっかりやり続けて
31年目になりました
みなさんよくドローンドローンって
言ってますけども
たくさんプロペラ付いているのが
ドローンだと思っている人の方が多いですよね
ラジコンヘリコプター
無人航空機のことをドローンといいまして
ですからドローンというものを活用して31年
ただただ空撮をやってきました
私の人生 好きなことばっかりを
ずっと若いころからやってきて
最初はもうスノーボードから始めて
スノーボードがまだスキー場で
滑っちゃいけないと言われている頃から
スノーボードを普及させようと思って
一生懸命頑張って
やっと長野オリンピックで正式種目となり
そこのコーディネーションを
全部やらせてもらい
そして 2006年のトリノオリンピックがあり
イタリアから４日間の生中継の
スノーボードの競技解説を
僕がやらせてもらいました
それをやりながら
既にラジコンヘリコプターの
空撮もずっとやってた訳ですね
結局 自分の人生好きなことしかやっていない
好きなことやってるから
１年中働いてもなんも辛くない
今年 半年で休んだ日にちは ２日くらいかな
これから半年後もスケジュールは
結構 いっぱいですけども
10日間は休みはないですね 年間でね
好きなことばかりやってるんで
これは僕らにとって もはや休日であると
好きなことばかりやっているので
（拍手）（笑）
ありがとうございます
どちらかというと
こういう方が負担になっていると
（笑）
だって好きなことやってないんだもん
飛ばすことが好きだからね
で ラジコンをずっとやり続けて
１機1000万円ぐらいの
ヘリコプターを買ってですね
そして 何機か買ってやるんですけども
仕事なんてあるわけないですわ その時代に
で 年間２件か３件ぐらいの
空撮の依頼があるんですよ
でも 2000万か3000万かけてですよ
そんなもん 儲かる訳がないですよ
で 請川は どうしてこの20何年も
飯食えないでやってこられたのかと
これは通常だと 会社だったら
もうその事業部はやめなさいと
もうちゃんと働いた方がいいよ
と言われるんですよ
でもスノーボードでもずっとやってきた
好きなことばっかり
ラジコンヘリコプターも
絶対これはいけるはずだと思いつつ
やり続けてきたんですけども
これを助けてくれたのは
農家の方だったんですよね
自分にその技術があるんだったら
農薬散布をやってみないかと
その技術で散布をやってみないかと言われて
農薬散布ヘリコプターをずっと飛ばし続けて
20日間ぐらいの農薬散布
この時期に得たお金が
年間1000万ぐらいなんですよ
（客席）へぇー
20日間ぐらいで年間1000万円ぐらい
貰えるんですよ
それがずっとやれたので
空撮っていうのをそのお金を貯めながら
やってこられる訳ですね
それでないとやれる訳がないですよね
それでずっとやり続けて
今までやってきました
で 数年前何かが起きたんですよ
「マルチコプター」っていう
プロペラ付いたやつ —
マルチコプターって
言うんですけど僕らはね —
それを続けてやって撮影したんですけども
数年前 首相官邸にドローンが墜落しました
やっとこれからだと思った時です
やっと20何年 —
27〜8年頑張ってきた時に —
首相官邸に心のないパイロットが
そういうことをする
マラソン大会で墜落をする
ドローン＝悪のイメージ
ですよね？ — でした
今ではどうでしょう？
ドローンの専門学校があるんです
そしてドローンを国が認めて
認定証を出し始めたんです
もはや専門学校なんて 当時から考えたら
悪の集まりの場所ですよ
（笑）
そうなんですよ
それが あれから数年経っただけで
ドローンを 専門学校で教えるようになり
2020年の東京オリンピックでは
ドローンを活用して８Ｋ映像で
世界に送り届けようかという時にです
今 ドローンの国土交通省航空局に
申請されている数っていうのは
１万７千通です
１万７千人の方 —
その中に数名の方も書いてあるので
約２万人以上の方が —
ドローンパイロットとして生まれています
僕はこれから頑張んなきゃいけないのは
何なのかっていったたら
ドローンパイロットという名前を
この世に広めたのは僕でして
名付け親でもあるわけです
ドローンパイロット
当時だから悪のトップですよね
（笑）
これ以上の悪はね
奴をやれば もう
出てこられないぞと思うくらい
ドローンパイロットという名前を付けて
出てきたものですから
先程の番組もありましたけれども
ドローンパイロット請川博一と
これ一番最初ね 「ドローン操縦士」
という名前でいく予定だったんですよ
これはもう駄目だ もうもはや
ドローンは全部悪をやり続けたし
もう良いことしか無いはずだと
よしドローンパイロットでいこう
で ドローンパイロット請川博一として
出てきた訳ですよね
これからっていうのが
ドローンのイメージを
どんどんどんどん変えていって
何が今ドローンに足りないのかっていったら
何が足りないんでしょう？
素晴らしい映像が撮れる
揺れない映像が撮れる
素晴らしいことができますよね？
僕らは 年間300日ロケやっています
年間フライト数が２千フライト
もう無事故です
事故なんて起こしたこと無いんですよ
だけども落ちますよ これ 機体は
飛んでるもんですもの
有名な大きな旅客機も落ちてます
アメリカで上げてる
宇宙に行くロケットも爆発しています
僕らみたいなあのドローンと
いわれているものが
落ちない訳がないんですよ
落ちます
どうして請川は２千フライト
年間やっていて 落ちないのか？
それは 今日落ちないようにしよう
明日落ちないようにしようと思って
定期点検だとか いろんなことをやる訳です
バッテリーを調べたりとか
天候を見て
「今日は絶対飛ばしてください」と言われても
「絶対飛ばしません」と断るんです
風が吹いて危ないですもん
一度のミスが 僕の人生を終わりにして
Yahoo!トップニュースに載るんです
僕は
（笑）
ねぇ その辺のドローンパイロットが
落ちたら良いですけど
私がもし落ちましょう
そしたら 間違いなく
「あの有名な某テレビに出た」
バン — それは無いな
もうとりあえず事故だけは
絶対に起こしちゃいけないと思って
そういう点検をしながらやってる訳ですよね
そして 年間300日ロケをやり
テレビコマーシャルで
今出ている 日本で映っている
「あ これラジコンだな　ドローンだな」
と思われているうちの
７割ぐらいはうちの会社でやっています
ですから殆どロケに出ています
北海道に殆ど帰っておりません
だけど 北海道で生まれ育って
北海道のこの大地が僕の技術を育ててくれた
一体どういうことなんですか？
それは 飛ばせる環境があるからなんです
言っちゃおうか？
田舎なんです（笑）
北海道 どこを飛ばしても怒られないんです
東京23区じゃ無理なんです
飛ばせば 警察に通報されるんです
すぐ逮捕されるんです 航空法違反で
でもこの北海道はどうでしょう？
航空法に触れないように練習すれば
ちょっと郊外行けば練習できるんです
ですから 北海道の札幌や旭川の出身の
スキーヤーはオリンピック出てますね
帯広の方になるとスケートの選手が出てます
ドローンパイロットは
北海道の田舎もしくは郊外 田舎にいるんです
こんなこと言っちゃ怒られるけど
都会に有名なパイロットはいないんです
（笑）
この人上手だなと思ったら
「出身どちらのお田舎ですか？」
と聞いたほうが良い
（笑）
そのぐらい田舎にいる
僕らずっと撮影をして
空を見ながら 周りの環境を見ながら
飛ばしてます
空気が読めるんです
読めないのが一つだけあります
家庭の空気
（笑）
これは難しい
色んな所に気圧配置が変わるから
（笑）（拍手）
１階にいるのと２階に行くのと
これは 31年ドローンパイロットを
やっても全く読めない
突然 変わるから
（笑）
突然の気象状況くらいならわかる —
そこは変わらない
そこは駄目なんですね
そうやってやってるんですけども
僕らはこれから2020年の
東京オリンピックのパイロットを育成とか
それとか緊急物を運んだりとか
人命救助をしたりとか
いろんなことにドローンが
これから何をしなきゃいけないかというのは
貢献度が足りなかったです ドローンには
ですよね？
まだ誰も助けてないんです
誰も殺してもいないんです 日本では実は
なのに 殺しても何もいないドローンに
色々規制をかけられてきたんですよ
どうですか？家で使っているもの —
ナイフ、 包丁 —
何の認定証がありますか？
お母さんが持っている時に
何の認定証も無いんですよ
でも もっともっと
危ないものを使ってるんです
だけどドローンはまだ一度も
人を殺していない 日本では
ま ちょっと怪我をした程度
ですからこれは何なのかって言ったら
将来的にいろんな性能が上がってくると
何かに使われる可能性がある訳です
当然ながら
農薬散布だって
薬を撒いているうちは 良いですけれど
違うものを投下されると
大変なことになります
一瞬にしてドローンが
この世から無くなりますね
で 色々戦争だとか色んなものに
使われているようなドローンが
今度は 平和として
違うものとして使われようと —
カメラもそうですね 車もそうなんです —
元々 そうでしたね
ドローンも同じように 次は
日本はそういう武器を
使ったことが一度も無い訳ですね
無人航空機というものを
ですから 我々が今やらなきゃ
いけないのは 貢献度なんですよ
貢献をどうしていくかということに対して
やっぱり パイロットの技術
っていうのは必要なんです
指２本の —
言いましたよね 僕ね —
指２本だけ 自分のことしか
信用出来ないんですよ
全くそうで GPSを使ったり
あまりしない訳ですよ
指２本の技術と自分の
目視飛行だけを見てるんですね
ですから ここのトレーニングだけなんですよ
難しいこと言っている訳でも 何でもないです
ラジコンを飛ばす
ドローンを飛ばすことだって
指２本ですから
２本 ３本 ４本 ５本
手を足を動かしている訳ではない
たった２本
うちの親父に言われました
「地に足のついた仕事をしなさい」
（笑）
ホントはパイロットになりたかったんですよ
地に足がつかなかったです
「やめろ」と言われました
今ちゃんと遺言守っています
地に足がついた仕事をして
（笑）
スティックワークの技術っちゅうのを
今僕ら教えなきゃいけない
これは僕がもし 20代とか30代
だったらどうでしょうか？
教える訳がない
盗まれたら困るから 技術を
でも 僕はさっき55歳と出ましたよね
もうあれから１年経って
ついに56歳になってしまった
確実に１歳ずつ歳を取るのです
もうこうなると教えたくて仕方ない
（笑）
何なのかって言ったら この技術を伝えて
この後を継いでくれる人を
作るしかないんですよ
この技術を伝えていくしかない
たった２本の技術
今ドローンを売っているのは カタログ見ると
「買ったその日から飛ばせますよ
買ったその日からパイロットですよ
空撮ができます」と書いています
出来っこないです
１つ間違ったら 事故が起きるんです
ですよね？
そうやって事故が起きてきたんです
僕らってずっと年間２千フライトやってきて
300日のロケやっていて
事故が起きたことがない
そして航空法が変えられて
僕らはどんどんどんどん規制がかかってきて
色んな承認証を取らなきゃいけない
許可を取らなきゃいけない
難しいことがどんどんどんどん壁が出てくる
でもこれを克服していかなきゃいけない
でもこれをずっと放っておくと
どんどんどんどんまた規制も厳しくなる
そして2020年
東京オリンピックがやって来る
これは大変なことになりますよ
で 僕は立ち上がった訳ですよね
スノーボードの時のように
いつかはオリンピック種目となり
遊びだと思われていた種目が
スポーツとなっていく
それをずっとやってきて —
もうゼロからの もう本当にダメな
ところからスタートしました
ドローンもまた同じようなことを
僕らやっていると思います
全く駄目だったところから
ゼロからやったって
全然良いじゃないですか？
もうこの年齢だ
もう教えるしかない
全国各地でプロパイロット認定会
というのをやっています
これは何の国からも許可を貰っていない
（笑）
承認も貰ったことない
でも２本の指だけの技術が
一番救われるんです
今の航空機ってどうですか？
車ってどうですか？
これから自動運転化していきますよね
座ってボタンを押したら 目的地に着きます
飛行機もボタン一つ押したら
パリまで行くんです オートパイロットで
だけども そこの車のところに座るのは
公安委員会で取った免許持った人が来て
ボタンを押すんですよね それを
そして １億円くらいかけて
パイロットに養成された人が
オートパイロットのスイッチを
入れるんですよね
決して僕がそこに座れる訳じゃないんですよ
オートパイロットがあっても
ドローンはどうしてGPSを入れた途端
あなたでも飛ばせますよって
やっちゃたんでしょうかね？
僕 ここが違ったと思ってるんですよ
もうマニュアル操縦で十分飛ばせる人が
GPSのスイッチを入れろと
それでこそ 安全フライトが
できると思っています
そして その技術を伝えるために
全国各地で今プロパイロット認定会といって
スクールをしながら検定会をやっています
北は北海道 南は沖縄まで
毎月のように
次のパイロットを育成して
そこで育成してパイロットが出来たところが
僕らがヘッドハンティングをして
東京五輪を飛ばそうじゃないかとやってます
じゃあ どこが合格率高いかと言ったら
やっぱりさっき言った
田舎ばっかりなんですよ
（笑）
東京23区で100名くらい受けて
１人しか受からない 例えば
でも沖縄でやると15名なのに
４名合格するとか
（客席）へぇー
やっぱり環境なんですよ
でもこれからっていうのは
屋内飛行場が用意されたりとか
僕らみたいに教える人達がいる
僕らって全然教えられてもいなかった
ラジコンクラブに入った時から
[私は] 一番センスのないパイロットとして
クラブ員から思われていました
全然うまくならない
飛行場の真ん中で毎日ホバリングしている
ホバリングしているから
ラジコンクラブの仲間から
「請川来ると飛ばせない」と言われるんです
真ん中で陣取っているから
「どっか行ってやってくれ」と言われます
そしたら 毎日朝
河原の橋の下で練習するんです
僕はもう ラジコンクラブの
飛行場に行けないんです
そして センスがない僕は
毎日のようにトレーニングしました
毎日毎日トレーニングして
やっとここまでこられたんです
努力するやつに敵わないんですよ
ですから プロパイロット認定会
というのをやってて
合格しないようなセンスのない人を見ると
「なんか行けるなあれ 俺を感じるな」
そしてパパパっと上手い人「駄目だなあれ」
（笑）
だって クラブで練習していてセンスで
勝ったやつ 今はもうやってないもの
でもセンスのなかった人間は
未だに努力してやっている
はい
ですから私はこれから
2020年東京[オリンピック]に向かって
優秀なパイロット育成をこれからも
やっていきたいと思います
本当に今日はTEDx ここに僕を
出させて貰えるなんて思っていませんでした
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）